hello everybody my name is hello
everybody my name is a host hello
everybody my name is Martin hello
everybody my name is Mark about I guess
jumble my name hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to let's play
hello everybody my name is Mark Martin
welcome back with wait that was for real
it's time to keep going with this one
and welcome to mole hammers there was
one more game that the guy who made the
all the other games was one button the
too complicated for our brains to handle
that he made he made that he made it he
made another one in solid and he made it
mole hammers hit moles with hammers with
hammers and frogs and Dolls
don't bring that up again because I
don't need that in here anyway
this one changes everything it brings a
whole new level of complexity to the
game instead of hitting up oh what the
hell I thought you said oh yeah oh yeah
that's more like it
see now
come on
okay I got a little out of control there
I want to apologize got upset cuz this
game is [ __ ] stupid oh it is not did
you see that [ __ ] yeah this one
actually goes down when you press down
it was a camera on my fingers we would
see that was so much faster than him
every single goddamn time I was a boy
alright one more time
oh you just missed the game in a row
okay never mind
Oh
oh well whatever it was not that I
didn't like that one your honey who's
faster Oh
Oh some other commentary of Geoscience
Oh commentary is there
I don't know you're kicking the molds a
little bit of it oh okay you're gonna
have that one thank you
you can't have that one
[Music]
[Applause]
what's that that's exactly this entire
goddamn game is you're obviously not
great
[Applause]
always you just not better than me with
hammers and moles
oh you're so welcome it was my pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]
you saw how unfair it was posted why
were you only faster on the mall we're
both going for him I just get the
rabbits
your definition of the best needs a lot
of work don't you shut up
[Music]